si el presidente de la república
Guillermo lasso asistirá el día de hoy
de la asamblea nacional para defenderse
de un juicio político por el supuesto
delito de peculado un hecho histórico
que sucede en la democracia de este país
viene a defenderse luego de que hace
varios meses los acusadores
interpelantes de la asamblea nacional lo
acusara igual forma para
las acusaciones basadas en cuanto a la
firma de contratos con la mercante López
la flota ecuatoriana petrolera de este
país de crear contratos que ocasionarían
perjuicio al Ecuador luego de firmar
contratos con el servicio de transporte
petrolero amazonas tanker qué va a pasar
el día de hoy bueno el presidente de la
república asistirá a el pleno del
Palacio de negativo para defenderse una
sesión que se extenderá inclusive por
dos días comienza el día de hoy con la
interpelación de los asambleístas
acusadores ellos tendrán aproximadamente
dos horas para presentar sus alegatos y
esas acusaciones y pruebas en contra del
presidente República y posteriormente
Entonces el presidente de la república
presentará en su defensa tendrá tres
horas para defenderse y posteriormente
Se abrirá Inclusive la réplica entre los
acusadores el CD se desarrollará
aproximadamente siete horas antes de que
el presidente de la asamblea nacional
Virgilio abra el debate para que los
asambleístas uno por uno de cuenten con
diez minutos para presentar así el
debate en el parlamento usado ahora Qué
posibilidades hay dentro del hemiciclo
para que prospere este juicio
Esa es la gran pregunta que sucede el
día de hoy habría que tomar en cuenta
que esto es un juicio político y va a
ser a través de los votos Cómo se va a
decidir el destino del presidente de la
república sí podemos tomar Cuál ha sido
el comportamiento de la votación de los
asambleístas hace tan solo el domingo
pasado hubo un poco más de 90 votos para
reelegir en la presidencia a Virgilio el
podría entenderse que así será la
votación que se refleje en la votación
de la moción de censura o archivo en
contra del presidente de la república
Pero hay denuncias de supuesta compra de
conciencias hay denuncias de
desafiliación de partidos políticos hay
denuncias de cargos políticos a favor de
algunos asambleístas Y como te digo será
así la gran incógnita todo esto sucede
en medio de un entorno de elección de
las nuevas autoridades de la asamblea
nacional que estarán en contra del
presidente de la república el gobierno
nacional no cuenta con presencia en las
las principales autoridades del
parlamento por el cual también sería un
punto en contra el primer mandatario hay
también mucha movilización el día de hoy
en las inmediaciones de la asamblea
cuando los representantes organizaciones
sociales ha indicado que realizarán
plantones y movilizaciones para
verificar y hacer así lo que sería un
juicio Popular en contra del presidente
de la república